In this part of mesh optimizations, I want to talk about level of details, as these are very important for both your static and your skeletal meshes.
Now before I jump into what they are, I'd like to make one note about Nanite.
Nanite is going to do a lot of this work for you automatically, so if you're working on a project that utilizes Nanite meshes,
you can still adjust the level of details, but you do not need to do as much work as you do with just standard static or skeletal meshes.
Now, with that out of the way, what is a level of detail? Well, on the screen in front of us, we have this little cow taken from the content examples,
and we have it broken up into four different meshes. Now at the top of this image above each mesh is the number of triangles,
and at the bottom is the level of detail, or the LOD level that is associated with it.
And what level of details do is they give us the ability to show the exact same mesh,
but as that mesh gets further and further away from the camera, the number of triangles is reduced,
and just as long as we keep that silhouette intact and reduce those triangles, to the user, this is going to be an almost unnoticeable difference.
Now, level of detail meshes can be created for both static and skeletal meshes using a similar interface.
How this works is we define the level or number of level of details that we wish,
and then for each level, we can adjust the criteria for reduction.
We will have the ability to choose between triangles and vertices, and then a percentage that we want to keep for that particular level.
Let's take a look at this inside of the editor with this static mesh.
Now, right now, this static mesh has three levels of detail applied to it, so that's one, that's two,
and then if I go all the way back out here, we've got to go kind of far, but that is our third level of detail.
So you can see here, again, if we were this close right here with the default, let's take a look at this actually by grabbing it and hitting CTRL-E,
and then I'm going to bring this on the screen for us.
So we can see here, by default, this thing's 57,000 triangles, so when we are this far away, it just doesn't make sense to draw that many triangles.
We can barely see it, we just kind of see the outline of it, so that's why we want to reduce that when it's in the distance.
So to do this, what we're going to do is we're going to come up here to our LOD picker, and we can come down and select the individual LOD levels,
and I got this LOD picker by first coming here to our LOD settings, and number of LODs we can increase or decrease this number to give us more or less LODs.
And once we set that, let's go ahead and come over here to LOD, let's say LOD 3, and look at this, this is at 1146, and it does look a little decimally,
so let's set the triangle amount back to say 5 and hit apply changes.
We are going to need to give this a second to process because it's got to go and redo all of the level of detail levels that it has, recalculate everything.
Alright, so that is a little bit better, look at that, it's only 2800, so it's about 500 more than it was before, so that's looking pretty good.
Let's take a look at this in our project now, so we're going to close this, and then we just need to kind of zoom out a little bit more,
and there we go, that is looking a little bit better, and I think that's a pretty good result right there,
I mean 2000 for something that's going to be that far away is not too bad, so as we zoom in on that,
you can see here the level of detail is going to automatically change for us as the camera moves around the scene.
Now, skeletal meshes can also have this applied, but when working with skeletal meshes,
you're going to find a few additional controls and settings, as sometimes the reduction might happen in locations that are not ideal.
In the example in the screen on front of us, we see the mannequin hand, and with the default reduction,
notice that the finger geometry is kind of collapsing, and those don't really look too much like fingers anymore.
On the right hand side though, we've enabled an option called bone priority reduction,
and what this does is, this says, hey, when you're going to reduce, we're going to say remove geometry everywhere except for the hands,
and that's right, we can give the bones that the geometry and the hands are skinned to a priority,
and things with a higher priority will be very last to have their geometry removed.
Now, the next setting that I want to talk about happens to deal with open mesh edges.
On our skeletal meshes, we can also lock our mesh edges, and the reason I'm bringing this up is
because of the highlighted or circled area in the image on the screen in front of us.
Oftentimes when you're dealing with games, particularly games that have customization,
you generally separate the head from the torso, the torso from the legs, and possibly the arms depending on your setup.
Because of this, it will introduce what are known as open edges, and a lot of times there'll be geometry
that needs to fit inside of this open edge to complete the edge loop to make it look like it's one complete unit.
If you do not run the logarithm with lock mesh edges on, it will remove vertices, like in this example.
We see in the highlighted area there's a vert that needs to stay there in order for the head to meet with the torso.
And again, our tools are very powerful. They have the option to run the logarithm with this on,
which will exclude any open edges from the reduction, ensuring that your heads and your torsos and your legs and your feet
will all be put together and you won't see any gaps or holes inside of the model.
One last thing to note about level of detail adjustments, while Nanite does do this for you,
you will need to set your level of detail adjustments on any and all skeletal meshes that you have.
Let's take a look at how we do that inside of the editor now.
So I'm going to go ahead and hit control space here, and we're going to come here to our third person BP,
to our mannequin, character, mesh, and we're going to open up our skeletal mesh right here.
So here is our skeletal mesh, and to get to our LOD, we have our LOD settings right here.
And just like with our static mesh, we have the number of LODs that we can set.
However, we do have some different settings inside of our reduction.
We have triangles, vertices, first percent satisfied, max triangles, max vertices, and max first satisfied.
So, triangles is how many triangles do we want this to remove, vertices is the amount of vertices that we want this to move,
and first percent satisfied allows us to pick between the two.
So we can set, I want you to remove up to 12,000 vertices, or 12,000 triangles, and whichever one of those it can reduce first, it will stay there.
This next one, max triangles and max vertices, and first max satisfied, these are pretty cool.
This allows us to actually set a maximum number.
Let's say we want to reduce this down to 1,000.
We can put this in here, the logarithm will go, and it will reduce it right down to that number,
or a little bit above, or a tiny bit below.
And we can do that again with our max triangles, or our max vertices.
A few other options that I would like to point out here are things like our volumetric correction.
Here is our lock mesh edge option, as well as enforce bone boundaries.
And if we come up to our LOD info, our bones to prioritize is where we can add a list of bones,
and then we need to make sure that we set the weight of prioritization to a very high number,
so that when we run our reduction, it will only take things from that particular area.
Let's go ahead and take a look at our LOD right now.
So here's our LOD 3, and we can see here we've got some mangled fingers right there.
So what we're going to do is come to our character, we're going to go to our bones and show our bone names, and that's index 03L.
So what I'm going to do is bones to prioritize, I'm going to add a new item to the list here.
I'm going to scroll down, and we're going to look for, it was index 03L.
And now what I'm going to do with that, I'm going to say regenerate LOD.
And it looks like I might have not gotten that right, so one more time here.
Let's go ahead and show bones, bone names, index 03.
Let's go back up here real quick.
Maybe we actually need to do the one above it, so let's just add another one here.
And let's regenerate.
Hey, there we go, alright.
So it's actually index 02 that was the culprit, but you see how easy that was?
One of the other things that is really cool about this too, is let's just turn off our bone names here.
Let's come back up to our reduction settings here.
And we'll increase this to say 10.
Alright, and then we're going to say regenerate LOD.
Now, there we go, that put in a little bit more geometry in there for us.
Now, one of the things that you often have to do when you make your LODs is you need to make sure that they work with the animations as well.
So let's come over here to our animation tab.
And look at our third person.
Let's see if we got maybe the idle here or something like that.
There we go.
So here is our idle.
And let's just bring this down to our third LOD.
And what I'm going to do is I'm going to come back here.
And this I think is one of the coolest things about this tool.
So I'm going to take this volumetric correction and set it to a value of 1 and hit regenerate.
Now, normally if I wanted to fix this, now it gives them a super pointy head.
What I would have to do is make this correction inside my DCC.
Make sure that the skinned weights are transferred over and that basically nothing is out of place.
And that's just a lot of time, even if you have tools that are set up to automatically do that for you.
Now check this out.
Watch what happens when I come back over here to my animated.
Notice it looks exactly the same.
So let's just fix that so his head is not so pointy.
And we'll give this a second.
So there we go.
Now, no longer a super pointy head.
Let's come back to our animation.
Look at that, no longer super pointy head.
So this is really, really awesome because this means that we can adjust all of our LODs.
We can quickly make changes.
We can remove them.
We can add them.
And we can do it all in a non-destructive manner.
And that's what makes these tools so powerful is that it's the non-destructive nature of them.
Allows us to quickly iterate, run tests and optimizations that would otherwise take too long
or require too many different people in order to see if the actual optimization is a performance
gain or a performance decrement.